hey guys welcome to part 1 of a special
series in May doing a awesome bill where
I focus on the props and some of the set
pieces that I built for the nostalgia
critic Mad Max fury road review to date
the Mad Max review that we did was the
largest amount of perhaps costumes and
set pieces that we've had to build for a
single review there's a ton of work but
it was also a lot of fun I was probably
gonna build a lot of the props that we
used anyway so it was it was a cool
excuse and a good exercise for me to
delve into and build those props and
fortunately we also had more time on
that particular review to focus on
building some of the props and the
costumes and stuff so in this first
episode I'm gonna be focusing on the
first prop that I built for that review
but for me kind of set the tone probably
wanted the build of props and stuff it
was a prop that I have aligned to build
for a long time even before the movie
came out and stuff so it just gave me an
excuse to kind of delve right into it
and that prop is that Max's shotgun this
prop was primarily used by Tamara who
was playing furiosa during the review
yeah so I've compiled some of the behind
the scenes footage of some of the
elements I used in the process that I
put it together so yeah I hope you guys
enjoyed this first installment
so I started with a piece of conduit
that I cut into two 12 inch lengths as
you can see there I think I used
three-quarter inch and then I've got two
pieces of square tubing ones brass ones
a little home it's basically just what I
had so I used the smaller piece to
create a spacer between the two pieces
of conduit and I glued it using j-b weld
or I think I used JB quick which just
activates a little faster but it's a
really good adhesive for adhering metals
so this is the two pieces combined and
then once that was cured add a piece of
epoxy putty of a plumber's epoxy putty
and said the larger square tubing on top
of that to kind of get where I wanted it
make sure it was flat and it was even
all the way across
so that then I could fill in that gap
between the square tubing and the
conduit with more jb weld it's a
two-part epoxy that you can mix up you
lay it in pour it in brush it in however
you want and then you've got some time
you can kind of smooth it out which is
what I did there and you can kind of see
there's some bubbles and stuff I think I
hadn't even wanted to cut two or three
coats or whatever they kind of would
settle in and then I would put another
thin bead kind of smooth it out but yeah
then once that cures I cut out the
handle and all like the wood pieces the
hand the handle itself and then the
forward grip and cut out of a piece of
2x4 and just sanded the hell out of it
so and then the brake mechanism the
hinge piece I just took a piece of scrap
aluminum that I had of a little flat bar
and a metal spacer that I had that was
about the right size that I was looking
for
I had a few different ones and I shot a
screw through it into the spacer and
held it there with epoxy putty and
that's basically what you see there and
then I covered the screw head with the
epoxy putty so it wouldn't shift around
or loosen or anything and the deck notch
in there that groove really serves no
purpose it was just a scrap piece so but
you're never gonna see it so it didn't
matter to me I then decided how I wanted
to you like the body of the gun I once I
got there the shape that I was looking
for I traced it unto the the wood and
then I cut it and I cut three identic or
two identical pieces and a centerpiece
as you can see here then the centerpiece
is the one that's got sort of rounded
out notch kind of there and I
pre-drilled all my holes so I knew
everything was lined up correctly got my
holes there that's gonna drill into the
hand off
and then that's the centerpiece and
that's where my locking pin is gonna
slide through you can see it's kind of
effed up and do a very good job there so
here I'm just assembling the pieces and
see how they all go and where that
spacer is gonna fit the brake so there's
my finished handle after a lot of
sanding and I drilled a hole and created
a notch in the top there and that's
where my pin is gonna go or the locking
mechanism and that's my pin which is
just a sliding bolt for like a sliding
latch or sliding lock and I just
modified it by cutting it down and then
adding some plumbers epoxy putty for
that little kinda like
and they're right here I'm just screwing
together the body of the gun
you can see that I have to cut off the
end pieces but kind of just testing it
out I wanted to put all the pieces
together and make sure that everything
fit before because I had to rebuild
anything anything like that so there's
the spring and that's gonna go inside
the handle like that behind the pin and
are the pin slides in like that and
that's gonna be my my locking mechanism
lock and release for the the break of
the gun that slice of the hole there
and
and then this is the barrel where I have
now added the some screws or the forward
grip and there's my brake mechanism so I
use the jb weld and glue that piece of
aluminum to the conduit and then my
spacer there is gonna fit to the body of
the gun
yeah I put some epoxy putty for those
screws but it wasn't really strong
enough sigh also I had some JB quit and
there's the what word grip that I sanded
how the same 2x4 I think that I've
sanded a hand a lot of and again it was
a lot of sanding but yeah pre-drill my
holes then I kind of design the whole
thing so that I could break it apart
like a real gun I could take out the
elements apart in case something broke
and I can replace just that one part
instead of having to scrap it or rebuild
the whole thing so this is me kind of
testing out the brake mechanism make
sure it's gonna work before I put the
screws down everything
yeah and it's kind of like that's how it
swivels
does lock in pretty good so we're good
you
so at this point now I'm gonna attack
the forward grip and that piece that I
added there is gonna fit around the
curve of the body of the gun so that
when it breaks it doesn't swing like all
the way down it kind of swings down and
stops very much like a real shotgun
stand those screws screwed to the body
and I added a trigger guard using a
piece of aluminum that I bent into much
rear guard and then the triggers are
just they don't activate or anything or
there's no springs just pieces of
plastic that I cut into triggers and
drill the hole put a pin through it so
they're basically just there they kind
of move but they don't really do
anything and that's pretty much finished
elements before painting all right so
I've been working on this project a
little bit here a little bit there for
the past few weeks as I've been working
on other projects and stuff so what I've
come up with is this and I'm pretty
happy with it I'm gonna add some things
to it if I need to I can kind of repair
it but I need it actually for a project
that I'm working on currently yeah so
this is it it's pretty much done
somewhat I to think that I'm most
disappointed with is that break
mechanism I wanted to do it more like
the the real thing where you kind of
flip it to the side and there's a catch
underneath that'll break the the barrel
but unfortunately that was gonna take a
little more time because I constructed
the housing out of wood it was kind of
brittle so when I started to construct
it one of the pieces already cracked so
I just scrapped it I rebuilt the center
piece and then I just put the pin in
with the spring so you just pull it back
and it's never shot like that and then
I've got these toy shotgun shells that
came with a toy shotgun and they fit
actually perfectly into the barrel and
then you can still close it and you've
got your cool loading and unloading kind
of process also
I just sculpted these pieces for the
back of that
it's the barrel that holds the shell
that'sa sculpted out of plumber's epoxy
putty and yeah once I paint it all the
same color and stuff it should blend in
pretty well that's it
so yeah well we'll paint it up and then
by the end of the day hopefully we'll
have a pretty cool-looking
Mad Max prop shotgun
all right so after a quick paint job
we're pretty much all done came up
pretty decently looks like through a bed
Baxter's shotgun you know enough to
where if you wanted to make one for a
cosplay or if you just want to display
it on your wall next to your mathematics
DVDs or something I think you would be a
pretty cool showpiece you wouldn't have
to go into as much detail as far as the
working mechanism if you wanted you
could just display it you wouldn't have
to make the brake mechanism or anything
like that so for the paint job I used
two different colored brown paints they
use krylon colormaster this was brown
boots senton and i used red oxide and
the two of them kind of combined make a
pretty decent looking worn wood kind of
texture I first I did the the light coat
usually I'd do a darker and I worked
lighter this time I actually did the
lighter brown over the whole thing and
then I just touched up the edges with
the red oxide to kind of mirror the
effect that when you're you know when
you're handling a gun it's been stained
wood or whatever then the oils in your
hands are going to wear away the finish
on the gun so you're gonna have a
lighter kind of finish I like the handle
and where the places where like your
hands are going to the barrel I primed
in a black and then all these pieces are
just black primer and then I went over
it again with gunmetal gray so this is
only the first episode in this series
I'm gonna have a bunch and they're all
for mainly one production I've been
wanting to build this for a long time
this just sort of gave me the excuse and
it was a nice kind of
starting point for now moving forward
and doing a bunch of props for her the
Mad Max review so so thanks a lot